- [Mark] All right, PNutty.
- PNutty the Pimp.
- [Mark] Pnutty, where are you from?
- [PNutty] I'm originally
from Chicago, man.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah, the south side of Chicago.
- [Mark] Detroit and Chicago.
What, where'd you, so you grew up there.
- Well, I grew up there.
I was born and raised in
Chicago on the South side,
and then I came out here to
Los Angeles when I was 12.
- [Mark] Okay.
Tell me about your family,
you had both your parents?
- I did, but that was the reason I came
to Los Angeles because my
father moved to Los Angeles
the year I was born, you understand?
So he had been out here
and I had lived in Chicago.
So I used to visit back and forth
about when I was five years old.
My story was kind of like
the boys in the hood story
where he went to live with
his dad and shit like that.
So I was fucking up in Chicago.
Mom couldn't really handle it.
So she moved me to Los Angeles.
You know what I mean?
When I was about 12.
- [Mark] And how would you
describe your childhood?
- I thought my childhood was pretty cool.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean I was broke like everybody else,
my mom was a beautician,
you know what I mean?
She did hair out the kitchen,
But uh...
- [Mark] What part of Chicago?
- The South side, I was on
the South side of Chicago.
You know what I mean?
- [Mark] Not like the West side on Bishop.
- Well, not on the West side.
Been out there and stuff like that,
they're a little more rougher out there
where they got some
rougher areas out that way.
You know what I mean?
But the South side was, it was cool.
My mom raised me right.
I was the only child to my mother.
You know what I mean?
So she raised me right.
And was real keen on education.
My mom was real keen on education.
Didn't like me to play with guns,
instead of like, if I had a gun,
even a water gun or
something she'd take it
and replace it with a book.
You know what I mean?
That's the type of mom I had.
So, you know what I mean?
She did what she had to do.
There was times I came
home and the lights was off
and the heat might've been
off and stuff like that
but we made the best out of it.
You know what I mean?
But I also grew up being
and my mom was a beautician,
when she did work in beauty salons,
I worked around a lot of women.
My mom would call me
down there to sweep up.
I was the one that sweep up
the hair and stuff like that.
But that also put me
around a lot of women.
At a young age, I started
studying women and learning women
and being around women.
And I think that had a lot to do
with who I became later on in life.
- [Mark] No pimps in the family
or anything like that?
- Everybody think they a
pimp in some kind of way.
you know what I mean?
Everybody think they got
a little bit of pimping.
So I have some cousins
and stuff like that,
that might've got a little
money out of a female
here and there and might've
thought they were some pimping,
but it was a few pimps in my area,
you know what I mean,
that caught my attention.
You know what I mean?
- [Mark] Anybody show you the ropes?
- No, no, I didn't get that
'til way later on in life.
I didn't get the game
until later on in life.
You know what I mean?
I tried to figure it
out when I was about 15.
I tried to figure it out.
Because I had a girl, but she
was a dope fiend actually.
But she was bringing me money.
She kept bringing me money
and that's when it clicked
in my head like, man,
maybe I can do something here.
But I didn't have it figured out.
I didn't know exactly
what I was supposed to do.
And then I had a girlfriend
that had a gang of trick appeal.
You know what I mean?
She had just tremendous trick appeal.
And then she had a friend
who was living with her
and we was all at the Motel 6.
I was about 16 by this time.
And we was all at the Motel 6.
And I kept telling them,
man I can show you all
how to get a lot of money
but I didn't know what the
fuck I was talking about.
I didn't know what to tell them.
'Cause they kept saying
to me like, well what,
tell us how can we get the money?
And I was like, don't even worry about it.
I'm gonna tell you,
I'm gonna give you the game,
I'm gonna give you the game
but I didn't have no game to give him.
I didn't know what the fuck to tell 'em,
you know what I mean?
And what ended up happening
was I came to Los Angeles
and I went to school out here.
I went to Westchester High School,
Culver City High School, stuff like that.
And I ended up going to jail.
And when I went to jail, I
started reading all the books.
I started reading all the
books that I'm sure every pimp
around the country has read or
wants to read or knows about.
I started reading all
the Donald Goines books
and the Iceberg Slim books
who was one of my mentors, Iceberg Slim.
And I figured it out.
And when I came home from jail,
I didn't want to be nothing
but a full fledged pimp.
And when I was about 20 years old
when I first had my first ho,
they put me in a halfway house.
They put me in a halfway house right here
on Crenshaw West Boulevard.
It was called Help Is On The Way.
And when I got there, it was
a bunch of bitches there.
It was a co-ed, it was a co-ed facility.
And when I got there I was trying
to pick through the bitches,
you know what I mean?
Like which bitch I like,
and I was fresh out of jail, had muscles,
I was young, hung, handsome,
holding hoes for ransom.
And I was ready.
You know what I mean?
And I was looking and none
of the bitches was really,
you know what I mean,
what I was looking for,
you know what I mean?
And it was a dude in
there that I said, man,
that's all the bitches you got in here?
It was about eight or nine bitches.
And he said, well, there's one more.
He said, but you probably
ain't going to like her.
He said, she's a little short, fat bitch.
I said, well, where's she at?
He said, she's not here.
She's never here, bro.
I think they going to kick her out soon
'cause she's always leaving
and stuff like that.
Well she fucked around and popped up.
And she was a ho, and that's
why she hadn't been there.
'Cause she had been leaving,
going, selling pussy,
being in the streets or whatever.
And when she came home, she recognized me,
at this time I had fingernails,
and and I had a finger wave
and you can just look at me
and tell I was some pimping.
And me and her had ended up
conversating and we got tight.
And I showed the bitch
my photo album and shit,
a little bullshit photo album
I had put together, right?
And I asked her to do my hair.
And she brought me in
the female's cottage.
And I wasn't supposed to
be in the females cottage.
You know what I mean?
And it was just me and her.
And she was in there doing my hair.
And she had a big ass
tattoo on her neck, right?
She had a big tattoo on her neck
and it said some shit that
I couldn't understand.
Especially, when you
tattoo shit in cursive,
you can't really understand what it says.
But while she's leaning over me.
'Cause she's right here,
leaning over me doing my hair.
So when she leans over me, I say, well,
baby, what does that say on your neck?
It had a bag of money, a
money sign and some more shit,
but I couldn't read the cursive.
And she said, oh, that was my ex's name.
And I said, well, what does it say?
'Cause I can't read it.
She said, it says, Mr. Mister.
I said, Mr. Mister?
Now you got to understand at
that this time I'm on fire
for the pimping.
I mean everything pimping
is just I'm into it right?
So I know that name
when I said, Mr. Mister?
I said, I only know one Mr. Mister.
I said, and knowing Mr. Mister,
I know he doesn't have no girlfriends.
And she said, no, I wasn't his girlfriend.
I said, so talking about the
Mr. Mister from Hollywood,
the briefcase, Mr. Mister,
Rolls Royce Mr. Mister.
She said, yeah.
I said, oh, you some hoeing?
I said oh bitch, you know what I'm saying?
We got some things to talk about.
So me and the bitch get to
talking and (indistinct)
well one of the people came home
and was like, Lil Kim, why
you got him in this cottage?
He ain't supposed to be up in here.
We need to have a meeting.
And they had a big old
meeting and long story short.
They kicked her out for
having me in the meeting.
And then I got into a
fight with some guys there
because I'm sitting
there arguing with them
about what's going on, trying to say,
hey, she was just doing my
hair and blah, blah, blah,
we ended up fighting,
we both got kicked out.
We didn't have nowhere to go.
She had a big ass bag of clothes.
And I didn't have but a couple clothes.
'Cause I had just got out of jail.
And long story short, shit,
we ended up on the bus.
We took the bus tokens we had
and went to Sunset Boulevard.
You know what I mean?
And that was the first
blade that I worked.
I was 20 years old.
We got out on Sunset and La Brea,
and I was green as a pool table.
You know what I mean?
I didn't know nothing.
- [Mark] You can ash on the floor.
- Yeah, but I didn't want to let her know
that I was green, right?
Because she had just out of
prison and she had been hoeing.
Now I was 20, she was 22 at the time.
And I said, ooh, the bus let us off
on Hollywood, was on the 212.
They let us off on Hollywood Boulevard.
So when we got up there,
I said, ooh, baby,
maybe we could do something I'm up here.
And she said, well, daddy, this don't.
This shit ain't been
cracking since the 80s.
And I felt stupid right?
I didn't know where to
take the bitch to, right?
I'm like damn, I don't
even know where to go.
But I said, I can't let that bitch know
that I don't know where
to take her to, right?
So we walked down to La Brea and shit,
we walked down to La Brea and Sunset
and we went in the bathroom.
And she said I'm finna go get ready.
And the bitch was baldheaded.
She had like, she was a white girl.
So when white people
shave they hairs short,
it's like fuzzy.
She had like a little fuzzy thing.
But she had a long bang right here, right?
And she just looked a little frumpy.
But when she went in the
bathroom and came out,
man, she was transformed.
She had her makeup on,
she had her earrings on.
She had a long dress on with
the slit down the middle.
She had put on from heels
that she had in her bag.
They was like some wedges.
But what really fucked me up about it was
she put a scarf on her head, right?
And it was tied in a knot in the back,
and she had the one bang hanging out.
So it gave off the appearance
as if she had hair.
But she really didn't, right?
But she was gorgeous.
But what I liked about her was
while she was in the
bathroom, dressing up,
another white girl came in
and I was talking to her at the table.
And when Lil Kim came out
and seen me talking to the white girl,
she didn't interrupt me.
She didn't bother me.
She did nothing.
She looked, I looked at her,
and she walked right on La Brea.
So the bitch I was talking
to, she was bullshit,
she turned out to be some bullshit, right?
She was trying to tell me
how she seen Queen Latifah
down the street at the club
Peanuts and all that bullshit.
So anyway, it was a gay club.
So anyway, I went outside
and waited on the bus stop.
And I watched Lil Kim, and I
watched her and I watched her.
She was over there on like
Martel street or something.
And I'm watching her and
I seen her flag a car down
or a car came up to her and I
watched her walk up to the car
and shit, it's just new to me.
I ain't never did it.
I done read about it, heard
about it, talked about it,
but this is the first
time I'm doing this shit.
So I see her and boom, she gets in the car
and the car drives off.
And I don't know at that moment,
if I'm ever going to see the bitch again.
I got all her bags.
I got all my bags.
Man about seven, eight minutes later,
the car pulled back up.
She got out, she got out fixing her shit.
Back then we had payphones.
So I walked across to the payphone.
I was acting like I was on a payphone
but I really had no money
for the goddamn payphone.
I jumped on the payphone.
She walked up to me.
I said, how much you got?
She said, I got 75.
I said, give it to me.
Boom, she gave me the money.
I went down the street.
I tried to get a room at the Days Inn.
I didn't have enough.
So they said go across the street.
I went to this little bullshit
room across the street
on Highland and Sunset.
And I took all our bags
and carried them in there.
I remember telling that story
to one of my older pimp partners later on.
And he said, what you was doing
carrying the bitch's bags, pimping?
You know what I'm saying?
You supposed to let the bitch
carry the bags, pimping.
Whoa whoa whoa.
But I said, I'm green,
I ain't know, right?
So I'm carrying the bags and shit,
and I take it and put it in the room
and she went right back out.
And all that at night,
she just kept coming in,
50s, 100s, 50s, 100s, she just worked,
and she was just so fucking trained.
You can tell she really
represented Mr. Mister,
really, really well,
and that's what a ho
translates to other pimps
and people around the world,
when she comes and she's trained
and she's laced like that.
And she says, oh, I just
came from Peanut and a pimp,
or I was with Peanut at
a pimp, blah, blah, blah.
You can see that she got
some good instructions
and some good game from that person
because she was so fucking
trained that it was amazing.
I mean, I remember when we rode
up there we were on the bus
and a preacher jumped
on the back of the bus,
and he seen that we was in distress,
and he started talking
and he was like, yeah,
do you believe in God,
have you ever been saved?
And I'm talking to him like
yeah, yeah, all that shit
good, good, good.
And she's looking out the window.
So he looked at me, he
said, is this your girl?
I said, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So he says, hey, young lady,
I was just wanting to talk to you about,
your life and things like that,
and are you okay?
And blah, blah, blah.
And she just kept looking out the window.
So she's ignoring him, I'm embarrassed.
I don't know why she's
not talking to him, right?
So he's steady talking to
her and she's not talking.
So he looks at me, confused
he says, hey, she don't talk?
I said, I don't think she's
feeling too good right now,
but I don't really know
why the fuck she's not talking, right?
Well, come to find out
what she's doing is she's being in pocket.
She's being a good ho.
Hoes don't talk to nobody but tricks,
they daddy, and maybe the clerk
at the goddamn Burger King.
You know what I'm saying?
That's about it.
And she went right in pocket.
She said, I'm finna fuck with you.
I'm not finna talk to nobody.
I don't give a fuck if he's
a preacher or who he is
I'm not talking to nobody.
My green ass, I didn't even know
that's what was supposed to be happening.
You know what I mean?
But as I learned and I talked to her
and we got to talking and I
remember one time I was riding
down the street and I was
so happy to have a ho.
You know what I mean?
I was riding down the
street with my friends,
and I went and got some of my
friends, my square friends,
and I said, man, I got a ho.
I got a ho.
I'm on Sunset Boulevard.
I got a room, take me back
up there, blah, blah, blah.
And they took me back.
And as I was going down Sunset Boulevard
she just happened to be
walking down the street.
So now it's time for me to show off
so I'm riding in the car and I said,
hey, look that's the bitch right there.
That's my ho.
I'm hollering out the window, Kim, Kim!
No, no, no.
I start off I say, hey,
little mama, hey little mama.
She just keep walking.
So now I'm getting a little
embarrassed with my friends,
'cause she's ignoring me, right?
So I'm like, hey baby girl,
you shorty looking good.
She keep walking.
So now I'm mad.
So I'm like, Kim, Lil Kim!
She turned around.
I said, bitch I know
you hear me calling you!
She said, oh daddy, I'm so sorry.
She said, but you know what?
I just got with you.
She said, I haven't trained
myself to learn your voice yet.
She said, 'cause I don't want to hear
nobody else's voice, but yours.
So I'm just learning your voice.
I heard you calling me,
but I didn't know if you
was just another pimp
trying to call me or what.
You know what I mean?
But I won't let that happen again.
- [Mark] What do you think the basis is
of that dedication that these females
will have to their pimp?
'Cause I've heard it many, many times
where they give him all their money.
They do everything they can for him.
- Well, it's vice versa.
'Cause I do everything I can for them too.
You understand what I'm saying?
- [Mark] So many things are misunderstood
about this game.
- It's a whole lot of
things misunderstood,
but the thing is, real
pimps have long since
stopped trying to explain
this to the outside world.
You understand what I'm saying?
Because you know I was just
reading something the other day
where they said trying to
explain this game to a square.
It's like trying to
teach a blind man colors.
You understand what I'm saying?
It's just not gonna happen,
they're never gonna understand it,
they'll never understand
why she does these things
and comes back and
gives you all her money.
But even square women.
I mean maybe with the exception of Oprah,
you know what I mean?
Are bad money managers,
I've had women tell me.
That's why I'm so confident
in saying it on your show.
Women have told me I can't
manage money for shit.
When I get money, I do this.
I mean square women, white women
all around the United States,
black women all are thinking
they're not that great with money.
You have your exceptions,
but they're not that great,
that men think different.
You know what I mean?
So I'm an exceptional money manager.
I don't do drugs.
I don't have habits except
for these fucking cigarettes.
You know what I mean?
And, I'm gonna take that money
that you can make way better than I can
because I can't walk down
the Boulevard and catch that.
I'm just not that cute.
You know what I'm saying?
It just don't work like that for me.
I can take my shirt
off, I can do all that,
people are not gonna stop.
Women can walk down the street
and actually have a man pull up and say,
goddamn, you're gorgeous, how much?
- [Mark] What gives a girl trick appeal
as you call it?
- I think it's a certain
sexiness that they have.
You know what I mean?
It's a certain sexiness
because she doesn't have to be
the most beautiful woman.
I've taken women and transformed
them because I understand,
first of all I understand how men think.
Okay, and I think that's
a very, very key element
to being in this profession, okay?
We are as men, visual creatures,
we thrive off of what we see,
we can watch a porno
movie and get aroused.
As where a female can
read a poem or a book
and become aroused, they're
more mentally stimulated.
Do you understand?
So now we know that we're catering
to the visual side of men.
So now what we have to do is make her look
visually appealing to men.
You understand what I'm saying?
So they always say, why are
your girls out there half naked?
You know, they say, oh, that must be
one of PNutty's bitches
because she's half naked.
You understand what I'm saying?
Well, I know what stops them.
I know what stops the tricks.
I know what makes them stop.
Shit, we got squares, and
square bitches and shit,
driving, like, oh my god, is her ass out?
Is that her pussy?
Duh duh duh.
But they're stopping.
They want to talk to her,
he's on his way to work
and he see all that ass,
he's like, goddamn, wait.
Hey, I'll bust a u-turn.
You understand what I'm saying?
But at the same time, back
to your original question.
Okay so now you making all this money,
but at the end of the day,
you don't have a room,
you just went and bought
a bunch of makeup,
you got your nails done,
you got some heels, you look beautiful,
But you don't have a car.
You're not getting anywhere,
you're not going anywhere with this hustle
and this shit is not gonna last forever,
you're not gonna be beautiful forever,
I'm not gonna be.
You know what I mean?
We're not gonna be good
looking people forever.
That pussy's not gonna sell
forever, you understand?
So you need to use what
you got now to get ahead,
because this is not, I have
a lot of mentors in this game
because I'm very, very dedicated it,
Bishop is one,
Shantay who you need to talk to is one,
Kenny Red is one,
these are my mentors.
And like Shantay said,
this game is a temporary stepping stone
to the rest of your life.
This is not meant to be in this forever.
I mean, we have this in us,
so it's gonna be a part of us forever.
But at some time, at some
point I can't be spending hours
and hours up and riding
down the blade and doing
out cars and in cars.
That shit takes a toll on you, man.
And it's stressful.
It's stressful every time a
woman goes out to the streets.
Because I'm wondering, is
something gonna happen to her?
Is she gonna be okay?
Is she gonna be safe?
Is this the night that somebody robs her,
rapes her, kidnaps her.
So I'm always worried that
every time she goes out.
Regardless of what these
other niggas try to say,
'cause you got a million zillion niggas
in this whole country
that claim they pimps
and think they pimps,
but it might only be maybe 20 real pimps
in the whole damn country.
Now I'm exaggerating.
but you understand what I'm trying to say.
It may only really be 20 real
pimps in the whole country.
All these other motherfuckers
is talking and shit, hey.
Because you got a lot
of different viewpoints
about what this game is
about and how to play it
and you got your Bilbo.
AKA Alfred Golson is also
another one of my mentors.
And he broke it down and he said,
there's 52 different types of pimps.
There's the white ho pimp,
there's the black ho pimp,
there's the six ho pimp.
there's the upper,
you got all these
different types of pimps.
So you're gonna hear a
lot of different theories
when it comes to this
game, you understand?
But there is only a
certain way that this shit
is supposed to be played.
And that way to me, my philosophy,
and the philosophy that I believe in
with other real pimps is
that this is my woman.
Like Kenny Red told you.
A prostitute is like your wife.
You understand what I'm saying?
So I don't care any less
for her than I would a woman
that's not a prostitute, you understand?
I love her, you understand?
I love her and I love
what she does for me.
Now there's people that's
watching this and say, oh man,
you loving a ho, nigga that ain't pimping.
I don't even want to hear that.
You understand what I'm saying?
Because if I'm with my
cat or my dog long enough
I'm gonna develop love for it.
You understand what I'm saying?
So how can I not love this human being
who is going out there taking
a penitentiary chance for me.
Going out there and taking
a life chance for me,
she could lose her life at any minute.
She could be raped, robbed,
she could catch a
disease, health problems.
And then she comes back and
she gives me all her money,
and trusts me to do the
right thing with the money.
Meaning I'm giving you all my money,
why in the fuck are we still walking?
Why in the fuck don't
we have anything to eat?
Why in the fuck are we not living
in an apartment or a home
or a house or something?
So that's trust.
She's trusting you to take her money
and do what needs to be done for her
and take care of her with it, right?
So how could I not love that?
How could I love anything other than that?
So, yes, I love her.
You know what I mean?
And I'm gonna love her,
and hopefully she's going to
love me to a certain degree,
but it's a different type of love.
It's not a square's love,
it's the pimp's love,
it's not a square's love,
it's the hoes love, you understand?
We have a whole different type of love
because pimps and hoes
are different creatures.
We're different from the square world.
So we love just like squares love,
but we have a pimps and
hoes love between us.
We care for each other the same way
but we care in a pimp and a ho fashion.
We make up the pimp and ho community.
The pimp and ho lifestyle, you understand?
If I have a baby, it's gonna be with a ho,
because I'm not dealing
with square bitches.
I don't really deal
with no square bitches.
I don't even think I know none.
I meet square bitches all
the time in the streets.
And I got the numbers in my phone
and I don't even fucking call them,
because my life is revolved
around pimps and hoes.
- [Mark] What is the origin of pimping?
I mean, you think it's been around for
hundreds of years or?
- Well they got a lot of,
they got a lot of
different stories about it,
you know what I mean?
So they talk about the Bible.
But when they talk about the
Bible, they talk about how
Sarah, Abraham and Hagar
and how Hagar was like a ho,
and she ran off cause Sarah ran her off
and she ran into the wilderness
and she started hoeing
and blah, blah, blah.
They didn't mention
anything about no pimping,
but at the same time where there's a woman
there are gonna be men.
And she's going to have a man somewhere.
Now, if she's getting an income,
whether it's from Burger King,
whether it's from throwing rocks
or whether it's from selling pussy.
Surely she's gonna take care of her man.
You know what I mean?
If she loves him.
Now they also have another
theory that brings us further up.
And this was a theory that was developed
by older pimps and shit.
When they said that
slavery had a lot to do
with the origin of
pimping, you understand?
They try to say that,
you have to understand
that during the slave era,
blacks were property of
the white slave owners,
so the white slave owner could come fuck
on any of these women that he wanted to,
because they were his property.
It wasn't rape.
Even if she was married,
even if she had a family
on the plantation, he could
fuck on which one he wanted.
That's why we got so
many mixed breeds today.
many light-skinned people
and mulattoes as they call it today.
Okay but now the theory goes
that once they freed the slaves
these white men still wanted
to have sex with these women.
But at the same time, now they're
not your property anymore.
Now you have to have permission
to have sex with them.
So now you got these same
women who do have husbands
and boyfriends and stuff like that.
Even though it was Reconstruction
Era, you understand.
You got these men they said, well, baby,
go ahead and have sex
with him because we broke.
We don't have shit.
We got kids and shit.
We don't have no money.
When you do go fuck with whitey,
as they call them, no offense.
But when they do go with him,
this time, go get something.
Bring something home because he wants you.
He doesn't want me.
He's not calling me to
the to the big house
to come fuck on him.
He's calling you.
So therefore, since he's calling you,
he's already hooked on that pussy,
because he's been hooked on it for years
when he was taking it
from you, you understand?
Now he can't it legally anymore
even though they still were.
They're not taking it legally anymore.
So therefore now it's time to charge.
And they say that at that time
the only motherfuckers
that was really doing good
at that time was really big shot gamblers,
motherfuckers that was gamblers and pimps.
Those was the motherfuckers
that had big horses,
at that time, they was riding big horses
and they had big hats and they was fly.
And they learned how to
deal with prostitutes.
They made prostitutes
and they learned how to deal with them,
because once a woman becomes a prostitute
she thinks different.
She looks at the world different
and therefore she behaves different.
Anyone who thinks different,
behaves different.
Even you, once you start
thinking a certain way,
you start acting a certain way.
So that's just life.
So once these women became prostitutes
they begin to think
different and act different.
And these men who were instructing them
on how to go out there and get money
learn how to deal with them.
Now there's a certain way you
have to deal with prostitutes.
That game is what they're talking about
when they say the Book of Game.
Because, but these dudes
didn't write this down.
They passed it down to
the next generation.
To their sons, their nephews.
Hey man, this is how you
deal with a prostitute.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
But now there's the next
generation who added to it
and they made it better.
And then you got the next generation
'cause you're talking
about the end of slavery.
So you're talking about
1863, 1868, blah, blah, blah.
Next generation. we're talking about 1900.
Next generation we talking about 1930.
Now 1920, 1930, here you got Iceberg Slim,
pimping up a storm.
Iceberg Slim was born in 1918, right?
By the time they had I think
World War One, World War Two,
something like that.
He was pimping great.
But pimping, I'm talking
about street pimping.
No cell phones,
no, none of that, no hey baby,
no back page, no none of that.
Bitch go get it, come on back with it.
That's all I can do is send
you out there and then,
and trust you to come back with it.
'Cause I'm your man.
And with that money, I'm finna
take care of you, and bam.
They passed that down,
and they passed it down again
and they pass it down,
and now we here in this generation.
But technology and all kinds of shit
has also fucked the game up,
because you got a lot of
different theories and views.
You got gorillas, which there
has always been gorilla pimps.
There's always been them,
even though they don't really
get respect from our circle,
from real pimps, they
don't really get respect.
You understand what I mean?
But you got all these
different type of views.
So shit is watered down.
You know what I mean?
And shit has changed.
But there are still
real stump down genuine
1000% pimps and hoes out
here in this community.
- [Mark] Is playing a trick for his watch,
or his wallet or stuff like
that part of the game as well?
- It's part of the game.
But now the question is, is it condonable?
Who condones it?
You understand what I'm saying?
Some dudes do that.
You understand what I mean?
Like Pimpsy told you,
you know what I mean?
I'm not gonna encourage
a woman to do that,
but if a woman comes along
that has already learned that,
that specialty and she's doing it,
then I'm not gonna necessarily stop her.
But at the same time, I would
love for a woman to come
with a new Rolex watch or
this, that, and the other.
But at the same time,
that shit's dangerous.
And it's not only dangerous for her,
it's dangerous for the
community because here it is,
my girls, let's just say, hypothetically,
my girl gets a trick and
she robs him for his watch
and his gold and his jewelry,
'cause he's drunk coming from
a party, whatever, whatever,
he passes out, he wakes
up, everything's gone.
Now when he goes back on that boulevard
he's looking for her, okay?
She may not even be able
to finish work that night.
Which she might not have to
because she may have hit a big lit.
But now it wouldn't even be
safe for her to stay out there
because he's probably
somewhere driving around
looking for her.
But here's where it becomes
dangerous for not only her
but it becomes dangerous
for the other females.
that's out there.
The other bitches that's
on the blade, my partner's
bitches that's out because he's mad.
So he don't give a fuck
who he takes it out on.
This bitch just robbed me.
She took all my money, all my shit.
Ooh, she took advantage of me.
He's feeling like a trick now
and he's feeling like a victim, right?
So now if he can't find
my bitch who robbed him,
he takes the next bitch
and does something to her.
Who knows how horrendous that might be.
He might hurt her, he might
rob her, he might rape her,
he might stab her, anything.
And you might be my best friend
and these is your girls.
And since he couldn't find my girl,
he pulled up on your girl who
has no clue that this shit
has just happened to him.
She's just trying to make a buck.
And here it is, she jumps
in the car with this dude.
And he goes through all the
regular shit, oh yeah, baby,
get in, how much, yeah, blah blah.
Oh we're gonna go to my
room and dah, dah, dah.
And next thing you know
he takes her to a room
and now he hurts her.
So that shit can bring
bullshit to the game.
You know what I mean?
That's bullshit that I don't
want to see that happen
to my female.
And I don't want to see it,
I don't want to see what happen
to no female, first of all.
But I damn sure don't want
to see it happen to mine.
And I damn sure don't
want to see it happen
to none of my close
partners' females out there.
You understand what I'm saying?
So it's like, it's an iffy thing.
Is that really what you want to do?
You know what I mean?
And then what happens when
they get to calling the police?
Because now here it is.
All these girls out here
half naked on Figueroa
and all these other streets, right?
And the police just riding
by, they see these girls,
they know what these girls is doing.
But they're not stopping them necessarily.
You know what I mean?
But now if they're looking
for a robbery suspect,
now they're pulling
bitches over, now they,
you see what I'm saying?
So now you done made this shit hot.
Now you done made the blade hot.
So I don't know if
that's really condonable.
I don't really push that.
- [Mark] Do you believe in true love
or is there always money
and security factored in?
- Do I believe in true
love or is there always
money and security factored in?
Explain that a little more
so I can answer it better.
- [Mark] Like a girl hooks up with a guy
just purely for his
personality and how she feels
when she's with him.
- Okay.
- [Mark] Or, is the fact that
he can provide something
for her or vice versa.
She could provide something for him.
Or she's gonna trade
sex for money basically.
Is there always a trade
off of sex for money
in every relationship?
Or sometimes it's just pure
love and there's nothing else?
- I think women learn as little girls
that they're valuable to a degree.
They know that, right?
Not saying they're valuable to a degree.
I'm saying they learn
it to a degree, right?
Pimps help them really understand it.
But since women were 11 and 12
men have been approaching them sexually.
Older men, all kinds of shit,
all kinds of perverted
comes out from women.
I mean, from men, that only
women get to experience
that men don't never see, right?
So they learn that they can
get something out of men.
Whether it's a ride,
whether it's some candy,
whether it's money,
whether it's, whatever.
They learn that, right?
So they learn that once they put theyself
around certain men,
men will kind of cater
to them and shower them
with certain shit.
And their mothers teach
them this and their aunties
and they teach it
and they run it down to
them and shit like that.
At the same time, women
are emotional creatures
and they do feel, and they
are attracted to certain men.
They're attracted to certain
looks, things like that.
Everybody has their preference.
So I believe that you don't
necessarily have to have money
or anything because look where we at, man.
We downtown Los Angeles, right?
You see whole couples in tents,
you see whole couples in
boxes living down here
but they thugging it out.
He ain't got shit.
He ain't offering her shit.
He ain't selling drugs, he
ain't pimping, he ain't shit.
But she's with him.
So it's something about him that she digs
that she fucks with, it is something that,
you can call it true love,
you can call it something.
But she fucks with him.
I believe that the aspect
or the addition of money
and benefits and things.
That can draw a woman closer.
But I've had money and I've tried to talk
to some broke bitches.
And they wasn't giving me no
play cause they had they man,
and they both was broke.
Both of them was bums,
and my money didn't
impress the bitch enough
to come with me.
You understand what I'm saying?
So I don't necessarily know
if that's a guaranteed factor.
I believe that is a factor
in some aspects of life.
And I do believe in true love.
You know what I mean?
And I'm talking about universal love.
You understand what I'm saying?
I'm talking about universal love.
I'm talking about, I could love you,
you can love me as men.
I'm talking about as a friend,
I'm sure there's a friend, a male friend
that if you found out he
had a plane crash and died,
you'd be hurt, you'd be devastated.
You understand what I'm saying?
So love is universal.
You know what I mean?
And love is for everybody.
Love is for pimps, love is for hoes,
love is for men, women, animals,
love is for everybody.
You understand what I mean?
And I believe that that's
gonna happen regardless
of whether you have money
or things like that.
I don't think that's necessarily
an element that has to be there.
- [Mark] How many girls would you have
in your stable typically?
- Well, right now, man, I'm retired.
You know what I'm saying?
Right now I'm retired.
You know what I mean?
I'm just right now, I'm
just mentoring to the youth.
I'm talking to younger dudes
that's out there trying to get it.
I'm still out here in the streets.
- [Mark] But when you were active.
- Oh, well, when I was active
I think the most girls
I had was about four.
You know what I mean?
I had four girls and that
in itself is a headache.
You know what I mean?
I just was just reading something else.
I think it was on Instagram.
Somebody put all these
pimps out here wanna be deep
until they got four girls,
until they're being pulled
eight different ways
by four different girls.
You know what I mean?
That shit's a headache.
I mean, I've been in a situation where
all the girls came from work.
I got them all in my
car and they all hungry.
They all stank cause they've been working.
They all want a shower.
One is like, get me home so I can shower.
Another one's like, daddy, I'm hungry.
This one's hungry, that one's hungry.
They all want to eat,
but they all wanna eat different shit.
She wants Taco Bell.
She wants Kentucky Fried Chicken.
She wants Burger King.
And this one is too fucking
bougie to eat fast food.
You know what I'm saying?
I don't eat fast food.
I need some real food.
Or she's a vegetarian or some bullshit.
So now what am I doing?
Am I DoorDashing this shit home?
Or what the fuck am I,
got to drive to Taco Bell
and drive here, look.
I'm gonna make sure
they got what they want
because these bitches just
came in the house with,
this bitch got 800, this bitch got 1200.
This bitch got nine.
I mean, goddamn, I'm not
gonna feed the bitches.
And I'm not gonna make them eat
what the fuck they wanna eat.
You know what I mean?
I'm gonna make them eat
what I want them to eat.
No, I'm gonna get you what
the fuck you want to eat.
You know what I mean?
But that shit becomes a
headache at the same time.
You know what I mean?
- [Mark] Do you have sex with your girls?
- Oh, most definitely.
Once again, I got to
speak on what Kenny Red
told you when you asked him that question.
A prostitute is like your wife.
If I'm not fucking my ho,
who else am I fucking?
If I'm sitting here
claiming that I don't fuck
with square bitches.
'Cause this is how we look at it.
The world consists of
pimps, hoes and squares.
That's it.
Now you're gonna hear gang members
and you're gonna hear
drug dealers and them
also refer to themselves as non squares.
And when we're in their presence,
we'll allow them to have that.
But between pimps and hoes, we feel like
the world just consists of
pimps, hoes and squares.
So if it ain't pimping
and hoeing it's square.
So now I'm saying to you,
if I'm claiming that I don't
fuck with square bitches,
then who's left?
I'm not fucking no pimps.
So there's only pimps, hoes, and squares.
I'm not fucking squares
and I'm not fucking pimps.
So who else I'ma fuck?
Who else I'ma have a baby by but my hoes?
This is my family.
This is my woman.
And these are my women.
You know what I mean?
But like Shantay said,
and I gotta speak on him,
another one of my great mentors.
Like he said, your dick belongs
in your household though.
Don't have your bitch down
on the blade, selling pussy,
don't have your bitch
on Backpage or wherever,
going, doing dates,
and while she's out doing
dates, you fucking the bitch
downstairs that ain't gave
you a nickel in yay money.
That's just wrong.
You just disrespecting her hoeing.
As a pimp you have the right to do that.
You can do whatever the fuck you want to.
But I consider that and we consider that,
real pimps consider that shit mispimping.
What are you doing?
You are disrespecting her hoeing in a way.
'Cause here's the bitch
that's dedicated to you enough
to go out here and get you some money.
And she got a pussy, you can fuck on her.
You know what I'm saying?
But yet you fucking the
laundry lady downstairs
that's got a whole husband
that's giving her money
to a whole 'nother motherfucker
when this bitch is out here
taking penitentiary chances for you?
So like he said, your dick
belongs in your household.
You know what I mean?
And I damn sure try to
keep mine in my household.
- [Mark] A lot of outsiders,
a lot of squares will say that
you guys are sex traffickers.
- You know what?
I think that's just a part
of this new propaganda
that they got going on.
Obama let a lot of the
drug dealers out of jail,
federal and state.
You know what I mean?
Freed up a lot of space.
A lot of people been
complaining about overpopulation
of the jails and y'all not
building enough schools.
Y'all building too many jails.
So they start letting a lot of the drugs,
they got light on the drug offenses.
You are a white guy, but at the same time
I know you understand racial
politics in this country
and slavery has never really ended.
It was criminalized, but
it never really ended.
They always felt,
figured out a way to
still enslave black men.
Even after slavery was over,
you had the sharecropping era.
You know what I mean, which
still was a form of slavery
and you go on and on and on.
Now what we're doing is
we're using incarceration
as a form of slavery,
because blacks and Latinos
make up the majority
of the prisons in the United States.
Right so now that you let
all these drug dealers
and shit out, you got all this space.
Well, who are the majority of pimps?
Black men.
Yeah you might get a Mexican pimp here.
One of the great pimps that I know of,
another person that I
respect is White Folks,
who's a white boy that
pimps astoundingly, right?
But at the same time,
they are the exceptions.
The majority of pimps are black.
So what better way is to criminalize that
more than it already has been
by taking something that was once called
pimping and pandering, that
carried two, three, six years,
and turn it into something
called human trafficking,
where now it's carrying
12, 16 and 20 years.
The minimum is 12, but
what better way to get,
okay, well I got all these
black men out here, pimping.
What better way to get them in jail?
What better way to put them in jail?
Oh, you're pimping, you're going to jail.
We get us a human trafficking
bureau and we get a whole set.
Now we're taking that a step up from vice,
which they've always
had a vice department.
But now we've got a
human trafficking bureau
that's specializing specifically
on pimps and hoes and prostitution.
Now we filling up the jails.
Like I said, when I first
went to jail for pimping,
there were no pimps in jail.
I was probably like the only one.
An older pimp told me,
and he was in there for something else,
but he ended up telling
me, he said, hey man,
I know young pimping, you
on fire for the pimping.
He said, but you need to
stop telling these niggas
you some pimping, man.
You know what I'm saying?
Because I want everybody to know.
Man I'm a pimp, I'm a pimp.
You feel me?
But at the same time,
niggas ain't, like you say,
pimping is looked down
on, especially by squares.
Squares are intimidated by pimps
because they feel like
we got some kind of power
over women that they don't have.
They get insecure.
It makes them insecure.
Just like hoes intimidate square bitches.
Because they feel like oh,
this bitch ain't gonna
never have sex with my man.
I don't want this bitch around my man.
It's a lot of intimidation
factors there, right?
So now when you go to jail,
you got all these tough
ass niggas in there
talking about, you a pimp?
Oh ain't that a bitch?
Nigga I got sisters.
Nigga, I never pimp.
I got a mama.
I got daughters.
You know what I'm saying?
What type of shit is that?
So my partner had to
tell me like, pimping,
these niggas ain't liking you, bro.
You know what I'm saying?
'Cause you went around and
talked about this pimp shit,
bro you need to leave that alone.
Then they want to flip it
about what a pimp would do.
Oh, I heard a pimp would sell his own ass
if he don't have, all
this ridiculous shit,
why I'ma sell my ass when I
got a bitch that'll sell hers?
That's ridiculous.
You know what I mean?
But they got a lot of negative aspects
that they like to
associate with this game.
But you got to understand you
had rapists, child molesters,
and pimps all like them,
they're in the same category.
I'm talking about like 1920s, 1930s.
So it was horrendous to be a pimp.
It was gross to be a pimp.
But now in our age you got the rappers,
and you got 50 Cent
making his song, P.I.M.P.
you got Snoop Dogg, commercializing pimp.
And then you got Suga Free
and you got Bishop and
all these motherfuckers.
So now it's fashionable to be pimps.
You know what I mean?
Now it's looked on as a good thing.
So that's why you got so many knuckleheads
getting in the game that don't know
what the fuck they doing.
They got a girlfriend and they like, oh,
well I've just watched a video.
I'm gonna be a pimp baby.
All you gotta do is
stand right there on 83rd
and Figueroa, you understand?
And he don't know the first thing about
taking care of a woman, because
that's what this is about.
This is about upgrading,
uplifting and loving,
and taking care of a woman who
knows the value of her body,
and knows the value of herself.
Because I hear women all the
time, square bitches say,
well, I would never fuck for money.
I value my pussy more than that.
My pussy is worth more than that.
I said, well, do you value your house?
She said, yeah.
I said, do you value your car?
I said, yeah.
I said, well, what'd you
give it to me for free?
She said, hell no I wouldn't.
Well, why would you give
me your pussy for free
if you claim you value that?
You understand what I'm saying?
So it makes no sense.
You see?
So our job is to instruct
her and teach her
how valuable she really is.
To teach her the fact that baby
you can walk down the street.
Baby you should never be broke.
Because pussy's selling
on Cotton and Cornwall.
You understand what I'm saying?
There's no reason in the world
that a female should be hungry.
That a female should be
broke, because pussy sells.
And the thing is, you're
gonna fuck anyway,
you're gonna fuck somebody,
and the cool thing about it is,
you'll go to a motel,
you'll meet some guy
that you think is cute
'cause he light skinned,
green eyes, long hair,
whatever the fuck it is.
You'll meet him, you'll go to the room,
you'll suck his dick,
you let him fuck you all night
off a goddamn rhino pill, right?
You'll wake up in the morning,
give him some more head,
and when the man come knocking at the door
for the rent money at 11 o'clock,
you or him ain't got no
motherfucking rent money.
Now y'all got all y'all bags
walking down the street.
But you broke, but
you've been well fucked.
You've been thoroughly fucked.
You may have bust a nut.
You know what I mean?
If he knew what he was doing.
You understand what I'm saying?
But bitch you still broke.
So why not do all that and still get paid
so you can at least pay the rent?
Bitch you done committed
four or five sex acts.
You know how much money you coulda got
for all them sex acts?
You done committed all
these goddamn sex acts,
bitch, and you can't pay the rent?
Yeah, it takes a pimp
to hip a bitch to that.
To make her understand that.
Like that's ridiculous to do some,
so how much do you really value yourself
when you gave it away for free,
being that you wouldn't give your house
and your car away for free
because you see value in that,
but you'll give your pussy away for free.
Do you really value it?
You understand what I'm saying?
So that's how I feel about that.
Those are my aspects.
- [Mark] One last question.
What was the most important
lesson you've learned?
- Man I've learned so
many goddamn lessons, man.
But one of the main lessons
I've learned is communicate.
Communicate with everybody though.
You understand what I'm saying?
Communication, communication
is the rule of the nation.
That's what they say,
and you have to communicate
with that female
and you have to understand, see,
what's great about this,
is that when a person
watches this video right now,
it's gonna be a bunch of shit,
they're not gonna retain
all the shit that I said
but the great thing about
it is they can rewind it,
and they can watch it again,
and they can watch it again
so that they get more and
more of the information
that I am communicating, right?
But when I'm talking to my woman
and I'm sending her to the street
or I'm sending her on a date,
and I'm saying, baby, look,
make sure you do this right.
Make sure you do that right.
For your safety.
For us, 'cause I want
you to come back to me.
That's the main goal.
I need you to get back.
So I'm trying to communicate this to you,
but I'm telling you a whole bunch of shit.
But guaranteed, she's
probably only retaining
about maybe hopefully 50, 60%
of what you just told her.
And she can't go back and rewind it,
unless you're gonna tape
yourself talking to her, right?
So you have to communicate
with that female
and communicate with her
sometimes over and over.
'Cause I know girls say to
me, okay daddy, I know, okay,
I've heard it, I've heard it, right?
But I have to teach myself
to communicate more and more
and more so that you get it,
so that you understand it, so
that you're safe out there,
so that you can go get the money.
So that you can come back to me safely.
So when communication is
right, the nation is right.
You understand what I'm saying?
And that's what I believe, man.
You know what I'm saying?
PNutty the Pimp, my church.
- [Mark] PNutty, that was great.
- Thank you brother
I appreciate it.
- Thank you man,
very interesting.
- Alright.